[Aplausos]
[Música]
el break sites como la energía nuclear
todo el mundo tiene una opinión pero
casi nadie sabe a ciencia cierta lo que
es muchos piensan que el éxito significa
que el reino unido se va a aislar del
resto del mundo pero los partidarios del
break si exactamente lo contrario
para ellos vex singh es sinónimo de
globalización en esteroides atentos
muchos temen que boris johnson quiere
convertir reino unido- en un singapur
sobre el río támesis tras el éxito
durante todo el año 2019 la expresión
singapur sobre el río thames se ha
convertido en el mantra favorito de los
billeteros como sabéis singapur es uno
de los centros mundiales del comercio
internacional tienen acuerdos de libre
comercio con casi todo el planeta y sus
leyes han atraído a millones de empresas
pues bien para el primer ministro
británico boris johnson la unión europea
es un auténtico lastre para el comercio
mundial y lo cierto es que tiene su
parte de razón
no no me he vuelto loco pensando por un
momento es cierto que la unión europea
es la mayor área de libre comercio del
mundo permite que 28 países comercian
sin prácticamente restricciones y
también es cierto que europa tiene muy
pocos aranceles con el exterior todo
esto es verdad pero también es cierto
que bruselas lleva años haciendo trampas
en eso que llamamos el libre comercio
[Música]
la guerra de las patatas fritas la unión
europea denuncia a colombia ante la
organización mundial del comercio por
las patatas fritas si habéis oído bien
hablamos de patatas fritas por lo visto
europa lleva años vendiendo patatas
fritas a colombia hasta aquí todo bien
europa y colombia tienen un acuerdo de
libre comercio así que todos contentos
el problema pues que bruselas se dedica
a subvencionar a sus agricultores y
gracias a estas subvenciones de la pac
los productores europeos pueden vender
patatas fritas a precios mucho más
baratos que los colombianos si a eso le
sumamos las regulaciones europeas que
son mucho más estrictas que las de casi
cualquier otro país es fácil entender
que colombia no pueda competir con las
patatas fritas europeas
y ya sé lo que me vais a decir muchos sé
que a menudo ejemplo nos has puesto esto
es casi casi un chiste patatas fritas en
serio pues bien exactamente esto es lo
mismo que explica la guerra entre la
estadounidense boeing y la europea
airbus y mis queridos amigos de visual
política aquí hablamos de algo con
consecuencias muy pero que muy serias
[Música]
en eeuu impone aranceles récord por
valor de 7.500 millones de dólares a
productos europeos
en otras palabras reino unido quiere
alejarse de todas estas guerras
comerciales y para eso el plan de
johnson después del vrac si pasa por
hacer nuevos acuerdos de libre comercio
con todos los países acuerdos que
permitan que reino unido pueda comerciar
con todo hijo de vecino sin
restricciones todo esto suena fantástico
el problema pues es que negociar un
acuerdo de libre comercio lleva años es
decir que para que reino unido se
convierta en esa singapur del río thames
los británicos pueden esperar décadas y
que pasaría mientras tanto pues que
reinó unido- tendría que comerciar con
el resto del mundo probablemente en
europa incluida bajo las reglas comunes
de la organización mundial del comercio
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es decir que se van a tener que comer
montones de aranceles con muchísimos
países mientras negocian mejores
acuerdos pero esperad un momento porque
hay una solución rápida para todo esto
si boris johnson tiene un as debajo de
la manga para poder comerciar libremente
sin tener que negociar tantos acuerdos
estoy hablando de estudio
boris johnson quiere impulsar puertos
francos al estilo de singapur en
reinounido exacto hablamos de los
llamados súper charts reports que como
no tienen traducción en español los
vamos a llamar puertos super libres
estos puertos super libres son algo así
como islas de libre comercio en mitad de
reino unido vamos a poner un ejemplo
vamos a imaginar que reino unido tiene
un acuerdo con colombia según el cual
las patatas tienen un arancel del 30 por
ciento pues bien en uno de estos puertos
un barco colombiano podría descargar sus
patatas sin pagar ningún impuesto ni
ningún arancel porque técnicamente no
está todavía en reino unido-
y ahí en ese mismo puerto habría una
empresa que cortaría las patatas las
procesaría y las convertiría en patatas
fritas congeladas y entonces una vez ya
tienen un producto listo para venderlo
el resto del país los sacan de esa isla
del libre comercio y pagan los aranceles
correspondientes ahora bien resulta que
las patatas fritas procesadas vamos a
poner que tiene un arancel distinto que
las patatas crudas vamos a suponer que
es un arancel del 10 por ciento pues
bien en este caso gracias a tener estos
puertos super libres los colombianos
podrían vender para estás fritas pagando
muchos menos impuestos y aranceles pero
ahora la pregunta es de verdad es tan
sencillo si es tan buena idea esto de
los puertos super libres porque no se ha
hecho antes porque reino unido
necesitaba un presi para hacer todo esto
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
[Música]
el legado de thatcher si algún día
viajas a londres y sobre todo si os
gusta visual política hay dos cosas que
tenéis que visitar sí o sí una es la
city londinense de la que hemos hablado
mil veces y otra es canal y work canary
work es la zona donde están concentrados
casi todos los rascacielos es uno de los
centros financieros del mundo y esto es
sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta que
canarias works era una de las zonas más
pobres de londres en los años 70
por aquel entonces este barrio
londinense tenía un puerto el puerto de
eyl of docs y este puerto estaba a punto
de desaparecer los nuevos barcos
mercantes eran demasiado grandes y
simplemente no cabían así que en los
años 70 esta zona estaba a cerca de ser
un barrio marginal
lotina
[Música]
sin embargo las cosas cambiaron en el
año 1982 por aquellos años la primera
ministra británica era esta señora que
veis en pantalla que se llamaba margaret
thatcher a thatcher le gustaban los
empresarios más que un tonto una
piruleta así que para renovar este
barrio se le ocurrió una idea muy
empresarial convertirlo en lo que llamó
una enterprise son básicamente este
barrio tendría impuestos más bajos y
regulaciones urbanísticas muy laxas
así es como montones de empresarios se
lanzaron en tromba a construir oficinas
por este barrio
[Música]
hoy en día canal y word está vetado de
rascacielos y es un lugar súper rico en
otras palabras que la experiencia había
sido muy buena así que qué hizo a la
buena de thatcher pues lo quiso repetir
hasta la saciedad en los años 80 reino
unidos se llenó hasta arriba de estas
llamadas enterprise songs pero no sólo
eso también dieron varios permisos para
crear lo que llamaron zonas libres
puertos donde no se pagaban aranceles
[Música]
gracias a este tipo de políticas nissan
montó una fábrica en mi casa el que
ahora da trabajo a siete mil personas el
problema es que estos dos ejemplos son
de los pocos que realmente funcionaron
en la mayor parte de los casos estas
zonas económicas especiales no generaron
todo ese crecimiento que se esperaba
según varios estudios más del 40% de los
nuevos puestos de trabajo que se crearon
venían de otros lugares del reino unido-
es decir que en lugar de crear nuevas
empresas lo que habían conseguido era
que los negocios se fueran de donde
estaban y se reubicarán en otras zonas
con menos impuestos en otras palabras
las gallinas que entran por las que
salen pero no sólo eso el gobierno tuvo
que gastarse una fortuna en carreteras y
aeropuertos para conectar todas estas
zonas especiales para que os hagáis una
idea el propio canary wharf tiene su
propio aeropuerto el aeropuerto de
london central que de hecho está en el
mismísimo centro de londres
[Música]
en otras palabras que por cada puesto de
trabajo que se generaron con estas
políticas el estado termino gastándose
la friolera de 17 mil libras conclusión
final en el año 2012 reino unido dijo se
acabó y dejó de darle estas licencias
para que estas zonas tuvieran impuestos
especiales así que la pregunta que os
haréis es si era una idea tan mala
porque la quieren rescatar ahora pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
mal
la terapia para hombres y toro mientras
reino unido- perdía su fe en estas zonas
económicas especiales la unión europea
hizo exactamente lo contrario puede que
os sorprenda pero a día de hoy
europa tiene más de 80 zonas con
impuestos bajos y pocos en ningún
arancel por ejemplo si nuestros amigos
colombianos quieren descargar sus
patatas fritas en el puerto de cádiz en
españa no pagan ningún arancel tal cual
como lo oís pueden almacenar sus patatas
tanto tiempo como quieran por supuesto
en el momento en el que quieran vender
en el resto de españa o en el resto de
europa hay una aduana a la salida del
puerto
ahora bien si ese barco colombiano
quisiera dejar sus patatas en cádiz para
luego venderlas a que sea marruecos por
ejemplo podría tenerlas ahí durante un
mes dos meses el tiempo que haga falta
sin tener que pagar prácticamente ningún
impuesto ni ningún arancel y diréis
entonces porque boris johnson necesita
un break sito para crear estos puertos
super libres en reino unido- pues por
esto
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el tratado para el funcionamiento de la
unión europea aprobado en 2007 es uno de
los dos tratados fundamentales de la
unión europea y que dice este tratado os
preguntaréis pues entre otras muchas
cosas dice que estas zonas económicas
especiales sólo se pueden emplear para
dos cosas o bien para ayudar a las zonas
más pobres de europa o bien para
potenciar algún tipo de industria como
energías verdes o cosas por el estilo
todo esto explica que de esas 80 zonas
especiales que tiene europa
prácticamente todas están en los países
del este por ejemplo croacia tiene 11
zonas especiales cuántas diréis que
tenía austria ninguna y lo mismo pasa
con reino unido
[Música]
y todo esto tiene bastante sentido
pensarlo bien la región más rica de
croacia tiene una renta per cápita de 11
mil cuatrocientos euros sin embargo la
zona de nic asher en reino unido que es
una de las más deprimidas tiene treinta
y cinco mil euros de renta per cápita
creo que está claro quién necesita
ayudas especiales y quién no verdad pues
sí sí lo vemos desde una perspectiva
europea reino unido no necesitaría tener
zonas especiales ahora bien si ponemos
la lupa sobre el reino unido también
encontramos unas diferencias enormes
newcastle efectivamente tiene treinta y
cinco mil euros de renta per cápita pero
es que el oeste de londres tiene 191 mil
euros de renta per cápita y como sabéis
en muchos casos la economía es una
cuestión de comparaciones comparadas con
londres las regiones del norte de
inglaterra son pobres y por sorpresa
resulta que estas regiones son donde hay
más partidarios del presi y todo esto
explica que justo en esta zona del país
es donde la idea de los puertos súper
libres suena como música de este año
[Música]
el puerto de time quiere tener un puerto
libre virtual que llegue hasta la
fábrica de nissan en newcastle pero la
pregunta sigue siendo la misma las zonas
económicas especiales no funcionaron en
los años 80 porque iban a funcionar
ahora y aquí es cuando llegamos al
concepto de los llamados puertos super
libres básicamente en los años 80 había
dos tipos de zonas especiales por un
lado estaban las enterprise vault que
simplemente tenían impuestos bajos y por
otro los puertos francos las zonas
libres que no tenían aranceles pero sí
tenían impuestos qué pasa si juntamos
ambos conceptos
en este caso tendríamos puertos sin
aranceles con pocos impuestos con
libertad de movimiento con regulaciones
laxas y sobre todo con los llamados
aranceles inversos y atentos porque aquí
es donde llega la parte más complicada
del vídeo
sí
la madre del cordero está justo en esto
de los aranceles invertidos os lo
explico con un ejemplo vamos a imaginar
que vendemos las dichosas patatas fritas
colombianas en reino unido pues bien las
patatas crudas llevarían un arancel del
20 por ciento pero el barco colombiano
va a atracar en el puesto de micas el
que en este caso sería un puerto super
libre donde no se pagan aranceles y
tiene pocos impuestos nada más descargan
los alcores de patatas los llevan a una
fábrica que también está en esa zona
especial recordarlo bien todavía no
estamos en reino unido es decir álex y
físicamente estamos en reino unido pero
el cargamento está en un espacio
especial desde un punto de vista legal
estas patatas todavía no se pueden
vender al consumidor final
[Música]
entonces en la fábrica las procesas las
cortan las congelan las meten en bolsas
y ahora ya no tenemos patatas tenemos
patatas fritas congeladas listas para
venderse en el mercado británico y que
adam jel tienen las patatas congeladas
0% y por cierto que esto de las cifras
de los aranceles me lo acabo de inventar
se trata solamente de un ejemplo para
que lo entendamos mejor pues bien
gracias a tener este puerto super libre
nos acabamos de ahorrar muchísimo dinero
en aranceles y lo que es más importante
hemos conseguido dar empleo a un montón
de gente que estaría fabricando en la
fábrica de patatas fritas lo entendéis
bien pues todo esto explica por qué
tantos británicos están encantados con
esta idea de los puertos super libres
[Música]
los puertos libres le darían a las
regiones del norte un empujón de 9.000
millones de libras esterlinas según la
consultora que se llama meis group
llenar el norte de inglaterra con estos
puertos super libres crearía 150.000
puestos de trabajo y las asociaciones
portuarias de todo reino unido están
encantadas con la idea como os podéis
imaginar los conservadores también están
felices y dentro del partido laborista
hay división de opiniones porque a nivel
nacional el partido laborista dice esto
los puestos libres si quiere boris
johnson son para que los súper ricos no
paguen impuestos y laven su dinero sin
embargo los políticos laboristas del
norte de inglaterra no te creas que lo
tienen tan claro atentos a lo que dice
mike y que es un diputado laborista por
manchester
[Música]
mein hill si queréis trabajos en las
ciudades costeras del norte crear
puertos super libres y la pregunta es
realmente hablamos de la tabla de
salvación de reino unido pueden
funcionar estos super puertos pues lo
cierto es que tienen más ventajas que
inconvenientes ahora bien tampoco
hablamos de unas ventajas increíbles
[Música]
pueden generar trabajos pues sí por
supuesto que puede generar trabajos son
un incentivo por ejemplo para importar
coches por piezas es decir en lugar de
vender coches terminados a reino unido
los enviamos por partes y los
ensamblamos vamos a decir en newcastle
gracias a esto se podrían crear muchas
plantas de ensamblaje pero vamos a ser
honestos el ensamblaje es precisamente
la parte más barata de toda la cadena de
valor de un producto es decir que muchos
de estos trabajos que se crearían serían
poco cualificados en cualquier caso todo
esto no son más que futuribles así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que estos puertos súper libres
van a convertir al reino unido en un
nuevo singapur compensará esto las
posibles pérdidas de un pre éxito podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios antes de terminar me
gustaría darle las gracias a una
consultora adrián opel group por
habernos ayudado con la investigación
adrián opel group es una empresa
especializada en investigar las zonas
económicas especiales y nos han ayudado
un montón para entender todos los
detalles de este tema esto no es un
sponsor simplemente es un agradecimiento
y como siempre recordad que sacamos
vídeos como éste todas las semanas así
que suscribirse a visual
y darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo darle al aik y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]